okay this is not the most important
aspect of the current situation that
we're in I understand that but I do
believe it's worth mentioning because
there's a very important media component
to what is going on in our country right
now not only with the protests and the
unrest and George Floyd but also with
coronavirus this happened early with
coronavirus and it is now happening with
all content related to George Floyd
protests police brutality and Tifa and
even Trump's comments about these things
YouTube and Facebook have completely
demonetised all of this content if you
talk about one of the most important
issues facing our country right now
YouTube and Facebook will de monetize
your videos now I want to be really
clear this is not me crying censorship
this is not me saying YouTube and
Facebook or doing something illegal this
is me explaining to you how they are
making the wrong decision and this is
how the soft suppression using D
monetization of newsworthy independent
reporting happens now I can talk about
the fact that our country is burning
down as relations between citizens and
law enforcement completely break down I
can talk about the fact that we have
three officers still not charged who
were standing there watching a fourth
officer killed George Floyd I can talk
about how our president is failing to
lead and egging on police violence but
we won't make any money from that and
I'll have to figure out a different way
to pay staff and to do everything that
we do and believe me I'm going to keep
talking about it because you need to
know what's going on and we can't leave
it simply to corporatist voices to tell
you what it is that's going on but this
is very ugly it is tragic in fact
yesterday we did a ton of coverage of
course of George Floyd the protests and
tangentially related topics all
demonetised on both YouTube and Facebook
check this out this is how important
reporting gets suppressed so okay
protests erupt and society breaks down
that was a fifth
Dean minutes segment I got a lot of
compliments about it spent all weekend
researching how I wanted to approach
this demonetised yellow dollar sign as
you can see on youtube also demonetised
on facebook trump threatening protestors
with dogs this is a scandal sorry
demonetised on youtube and facebook
police victims or oppressors hugely
important story nearly 10 minutes about
how should police departments and
officers deal with what's going on is
staying silent making one a part of the
problem this is a paramount issue
demonetised Trump says he will designate
an Tifa a terrorist group this is a
president misusing the State
Department's foreign terrorist
organization list to suppress American
citizens due process and First Amendment
it's a distraction from the real issues
it's a totalitarian scandal sorry David
demonetized and then of course our full
our show the full hour show which
contains these stories also demonetised
what are we doing guys what is the point
of all this what's the point of putting
in the work and you know it's a really
clever and great way to virtue signal to
say we want people dealing with
important issues we don't want clickbait
we don't want low-effort content well we
spent all weekend researching this stuff
violent and nonviolent protests
destruction of property as a form of
protest historically the six or seven
different components to the protest I
mean you know we're talking about a ton
of staff time and it's just like yeah
yeah sorry
our country is burning but if you want
to monetize what about a Kardashian
lying about being a billionaire maybe
talk about that if you want to monetize
YouTube says we want to be part of the
solutions conversations we want to
support creators Facebook supposedly the
same thing but if you even tangentially
touch the biggest news story along with
coronavirus then no ads are going to
play you might remember this happened at
the start of coronavirus as well we were
early on coronavirus we were covering it
early despite not only the fact that a
lot of
thought it was overblown then but
despite the monetization and we kept
doing it after like a month YouTube
realized this coronavirus thing might go
on for a while we can'tjust demonetised
arted to monetize it this is how you
nudge channels so that they'll opt to
cover you know some BS and more and more
of the coverage of what's going on in
this country the social unrest ends up
being corporate media and independent
channels get pushed away from it so
we're not backing off today's show also
I mean the entire show is likely to be d
monetized maybe there's a one or two
stories that won't be we are not going
to back off talking about it we have a
crisis the crisis is that Trump's
leadership has failed we have major
conflict when it comes to law
enforcement all of it needs to be
discussed but this is how YouTube and
Facebook are dealing with it so know
that if you want if you're able you can
support our work directly only about
half of 1% of our audience has
memberships but you can grab a
membership at join pakman.com if we can
get from half of 1 percent to 1 percent
of our audience supporting us it's game
over right I mean none of this stuff
matters none of the D monetization
matters so consider grabbing a
membership at join pakman.com you can
get a 66% discount with the code this is
20/20 don't feel obligated to use the
discount don't feel obligated to get a
membership at all we're gonna continue
covering this stuff because it matters
and it is it is once again tragic that
this is how some of the major platforms
where we get you know millions and tens
of millions of views a month between
YouTube and Facebook that this is the
approach that they are taking it's sick
we can fight it and you know even if you
don't support me support some other show
if you think some other show is doing
better coverage of this by all means
support them but we we have to make sure
that independent voices don't get sort
of softly nudged away from talking about
this stuff because then it leaves just
the corporate media outlets talking
about it we can't allow that to happen